well it's what are you wearing put it on
my blog definitely putting on my blog
now he ain't gotta be up in the office
to wrap trap it will be to hopefully
talk about ownership and leverage APA
protectors that out there's everything
oh good morning Today Show in a few
minutes and wanted to just say thank you
thanks so much wanna be a part of my
life without you on the Left North BAM I
paid to us what paper trails running out
a door down
I was the cheap neither I had that fire
ether that may the earth shake like
California shot ceases what that is do
the 14 and it's can we don't like three
big up this morning hello hello hello
Jimmy Jimmy quick do a nice job on your
podcast man and keep hustling proud of
you Keith good to see you Pedro way to
see you hooks on you checked out the UM
the Today Show
questioned verified reference PD Dora
Hong Kong can't wait I'm coming home
right now wait a second [ __ ] see you
guys
[ __ ] sir fall Tyler I have to leave
because he booked something real go
figure I actually have a job there like
you're up I just want you to think the
[ __ ] fake so you can [ __ ] go
they're ready for us yeah I gotta go I
was in the middle of good you [ __ ] up
the rock we're gonna do a d-roc contest
here we go T rock what the [ __ ] start
taking screenshots use this do you rock
what the [ __ ] hashtag in your post now
usually quote about the rock subscribe
come on gear och man your God did you
great self man thank you brother thank
ya how about a 22 just how useful this
stuff is or having a dual-screen by
yourself I'll be in the middle of
complaining
check what time it is and then you see
stop complaining you know it's really
cool
yeah I can talk to your ear off all day
but I'm a big name in this mansion I
rather develop I would combine Harmandir
I take care guys take care thanks for
for her oh man oh man antenna phone up
my last old above a quarter pound port
with a line say get rid of all your
produce net so got a hand know what
you're cool spoke to the other day I
transgress not this much she's also
learning challenge super Dennis [ __ ]
vacation literally I'm on a permanently
until January I'm on it
this is six months into this guy out he
was working with me or against the
clinic to another concern our memory
cells no I haven't seen yet
is the person remember too many a
traditional just finished thing goodbye
the crystals lemons worth bust for five
years
she's moving for family using Boston
that was in national screen bonus and
I'm doing Ryan Seacrest rehab for saying
about bonding and crying off what brings
everybody together here why is everybody
roaming around together as you know not
only is Jessica Alba an amazing actress
but she's an amazing entrepreneur with
that has an amazing comfortable yes I do
know and as you know what if Paltrow is
not only an amazing actress and an
amazing system she also is an amazing
entrepreneur the head is an amazing
company called Google I dunno
and you know not only is Gary venture an
amazing freaking ghostwriter for all the
trig stuff well what I was going to talk
about that you promised bro oh well
Patti she is one of your biggest fans
Carrie Patti I love you
that's me I mean I mean that means the
world to me that's why I do and so thank
you for that with them next time on the
la coffee we're going to blow up your
company
did you know I probably knew of did you
know everyone on this panel for a planet
of the apps before getting together to
work together I knew well you guys know
each other yeah yeah I met Jessica and I
could not yet had the extreme pleasure
of knowing Gary
huge mistake did you look him up to find
some inspiring things about him and
things that would inspire you
well they said oh it's a guy named gary
vaynerchuk's on the show as well so then
I had to go a little deeper on Google
and we got to sit next to each other and
formed the greatest friendship of all
time okay everything is of all true got
me down you know and Gary speaks like
like a superhero I'm the only one on
this cast that has not played a
superhero in a movie I just want to
mention that as well for driving not
because we're drew that goes ready for a
girl no but I'm mixtape coming out late
next year I'll talk to you about that I
need some distribution thank you guys
for having us thank you so much Marvel
published on manga you funny - Mazel Tov
I started reusing it when [ __ ] black
eye peas use it in the song and there
there's lots of huh forever that's like
music let's go okay back in culture come
in when I think content I think that you
strategize over what you do to produce
it right and for me I don't do that ever
there's never a meeting or anything I've
done in the last two years that has been
predicated because I do a vlog so I
think of it way way way more documentary
than I do content or sitcom or whatever
you want to call it I've become very
close with bureaucracy a sweet kid and a
great man and like I love being his
mentor and I've watched him learn you
know my you know listen I not success
nobody successful by accident right no
matter what it is so it's been fun to
watch them pick up on patience and
emotional intelligence of being the
bigger man he gets to see how I fire
people how I hire people how I help
people how I get to be the bigger man
when somebody's doing wrong by me and so
I like him and I'm a human like I loved
getting to know him and who come from
it's a lot of fun you know hi guys hey
hi how are you Sheba great to see you
moving monkey Brandon canes in the house
what's your favorite wrestling quote my
favorite wrestling club is probably
there there's a plane going by and I'm
not on it it's a very rare macho man
Mean Gene Okerlund interview where
they're supposedly at macho man's house
and there's a plane that flies by and he
talks about not being on it and I don't
know I don't know why I love it so much
but it's my favorite
I don't do jujitsu but when I'm 50 -
I'll take it up for three years and
dominate because we won the great fifty
five-year-old you just - definitely not
but I'm definitely definitely definitely
definitely definitely definitely in two
years doing something not Jordan not
Mike I've been saying you know boxing
MMA whoever wins the fight I'll either
take a boxing or MMA predicated on who
wins the fight I think I'll buy the Jets
25 years from now what's a twenty seven
twenty three twenty four twenty forty
two twenty forty two feels like the year
I'm gonna buy the Jets is my gut I have
an AMA today reddit AMA today 5:35 15 5
5:15 to 5:45 today I'm doing a reddit
AMA Eastern that means 2:15 for you West
Coast so what was your initial we
actually find out who each of your three
coaches it was super excited right
they're real celebrities and my mom
would be excited and I knew you know my
sister be excited I was excited that
they actually had a reason to be there
because I'm in the business world and I
know about their biz I know all three of
their business backgrounds I hadn't
known any of them really at that point
but I was I kind of had a lot of
confidence because I knew Apple was
involved but it was I was worried that
I'm glad that I'm the I'm such a showman
and I'm the straight man and the
knowledge based I was worried that they
would have like developers as you know
like who they have and so the grandness
of the personal brand but came along
with it plus the fact that they weren't
just famous
or for entertaining but actually all
three of them are active entrepreneurs
in this point of their lives and some
pretty serious success not just slapping
your name on a product was your there's
three member actively doing yeah it's
kind of interesting you know they know
what they're talking about and so I'm
super excited this is a serious ramp to
two groups of people right now 54 year
old charlie
who's like I'm 54 it's over no you're
not because you have 30 more years of
prime years you can literally do it semi
Frank create a great goose at 72 years
old 72 so for me it's not caring what
other people think that's exactly that's
the singular kick yeah yes you're doing
know why you're using self esteem its
self esteem you genuinely don't want to
conform to everything else because
you're not worried what everybody else
thinks and everybody else on the other
side of camera are driven by
insecurities and that's just the truth
it's not fun to say
it's why 90 percent of my content that I
put out every day my blog is trying to
build people's confidence and
self-esteem because once you have that
you do stop pick your chest did say well
I'll go first like my dad so I am a
hardcore salesman showmen type of
character and a fire I don't know if you
guys heard but this is true and as a kid
when I was selling baseball cards and
lemonade and doing all this stuff I was
doing around the neighborhood to make a
buck I was so full of [ __ ] it scares me
to think back to that kid
my dad when I turned 14 and I started
working in his liquor store he he thinks
that you embellish once that that's the
end of your relationship because he's
lied to him so his tolerance for
anything that isn't straight shooting is
so extreme and he was born and raised in
Russia he's tough like that he basically
that your word is bond
he taught me that and that absolutely
saved me from being the cliche that I
think I was on my way to being and so
Lourdes bond at 14 changed the course of
my life
when was the last time you went to a
store and physically bought an item I
find nothing I mean by now I mean I
literally think the last time I bought
something was when I went with d-roc
into that Nike store in a couple
episodes of dailyvee like four months
ago but some likes like I just don't
like [ __ ] like food things I put in my
mouth I buy like gum and sunflower seeds
but I don't buy [ __ ]
painfully introverted I recently started
this is what our suggestions for
somebody to hustle their face off on
everything they have to just approach a
new personal situation to get a partner
that can be the extrovert being an
introvert and being the back behind the
scenes person is a tremendous strategy
and something that you shouldn't hide
from that you should lean in on but you
need a partner who was the most
influential friend you know it's really
funny it's gonna be such a big shout out
I really think that my brother Vijay is
the biggest influential friend I've ever
had because he is somebody I just
respect and there and I loved the way he
was a straight shooter I think he made
me a better manager like he he just
inspired me he's 11 years younger than
me but my brother believe it or not I
mean I had great friends growing up but
for some reason they weren't able to
really influence me but Ajay my favorite
piece of content put out was Episode one
of Wine Library TV because it was the
first one and all I did was from the
second I decided that it was a good idea
I did it like literally within hours it
was in hours of deciding I want to do a
wine show on YouTube I did it and that's
why it's my favorite because it was me
living my thesis the the piece of
content I wish more people would consume
is my podcast
hashtag Wade Huggins UCLA college taught
you valuable business tools or do you
feel like majority of your business
knowledge came from other sources
I feel like all of my business knowledge
came from other sources and learned
nothing in college from a business
standpoint I learned a lot about from
college from from a growing up as a man
standpoint from from a swag standpoint
from a basketball standpoint from a
hip-hop music standpoint zero business
coupe traffic done boy I've been back
for me for such that the sunrise I'm
running up marriage taking up top watch
the scene is running mountains all right
I'll be here for two more hours with CEO
Ryan Harwood but D rock is weak and
needs to go to sleep no need to edit
Sam's promise consistently and polished
up photo with anyone that couldn't keep
up from its word a song like Barry here
alone without the talk [ __ ] brothers
basics like I miss Florida with the
small is if you need it
I got it ain't out of